ich appelliere an den täter bitte
stellen sie sich sehr mir das liebste
genommen
das haben wir den ball gekommen wenn sie
ein mensch sind und dann wissen sie wie
das ist wenn man das liebste verliert
und ich bitte sie einfach nur bitte
stellen sie sich der polizei
bitte es ist ein fall der einfach nur
wütend macht am sonntag kommt es in der
münchner hochstraße zu einem streit
zwischen zwei fahrradfahrern einer davon
fabio de hier links im bild
der 37 jährige soll von einem
unbekannten beleidigt worden sein als
sie ihn zur rede stellt schubs der mann
ihn um und fährt einfach weiter
fabio d fällt unglücklich ist sofort
bewusstlos trotz
wiederbelebungsversuchen stirbt er noch
auf der straße durch den sturz hat er
einen milzriss litten verblutete
innerlich
seine familie steht seitdem unter schock
jetzt sind wir momentan einige masse
sage immer so gut obwohl ich noch daran
denken wie man zum gestorben ist
auf diese art und weise hat keiner
verdient zu sterben
darüber hinaus hoffe nur dass er
gestorben ist ohne dass herr bleiben
musste fabio de war bei freunden und
verwandten beliebt dass er nicht mehr am
leben ist kann hier noch niemand glauben
gottes willen so aber eher meine gewesen
hatte der genthiner dinge gibt er war
mein schwager zehn jahre beschleunigen
den man sich vorstellen kann
wir haben uns alles geteilt so bin ich
auch sein trauzeuge gelesen dass wir uns
geliebt hat eine schwangerschaft wie sie
ja wahrscheinlich einmal ist besonders
tragisch fabio de sollte in sechs
monaten vater werden
seine frau erwartet zwillinge